on va montrer quelque chose que nous on
a fait une nouvelle épreuve ici c'est
car wash avec les stars certains me
dérange donc de 2 voilà de voiture par
deux hommes de lavage et de stars alors
ici ils sont sur le parking ce sont deux
stars qui s'aiment c'est gilles verdez
et issa regardez ce que ça donne ça
allait donner des notes des voiries vont
laver une voiture et vous allez donner
vos les notes il faut qu'il soit le plus
sexy possible là c'est reparti on les
retrouve
issa et gilles verdez alors ça et j la
balle et voilà ils vont chacun la même
voiture mais peu vain ils peuvent la
baie a ils veulent laver la même
ensemble à d'accord non non à chacun sa
voiture est d'accord très bien alors
attention nous allons avoir pendant 12
ans à l'éléphant bleu vous allez devoir
laver une voiture avec une attitude la
plus sexy possible nos invités et tous
les chroniqueurs bon vieux notre
attention
ok
les rires
justine dupont
à
il
ça tombe bien exceptionnel merci ça
vraiment eu ça ça a été ça se voit ça se
voit aller j'avais la baleine le même
toit une voiture gillet veut il et il
est mort là c'est une élongation et on a
un problème il ya quelqu'un qui s'est
passé chez nous et je crois qu'ils se
cassent la gueule
il
alors ça va vous avez tout cela est trop
fait on s'est heurté la la la carlingue
la voiture est d'accord avec ça ou pas
ça va très bien et c'est passé à la voix
la moitié c'est le problème était trop
seul c'est notre souci tiens je vais
vous montrer des choses on a découverte
une candidate est à nous a révélé une
info 1 c'est insolite sur les cerises et
isla bravo on n'a rien gagné
merci c'est vrai j'ai regagné
l'essuie-glace d'orb